the function f is defined as follows f
of T is equal to negative 2t plus 5 so
whatever we input into this function we
multiply it times negative 2 and then we
add 5 so what is the input value for
which f of T is equal to 13 so if F of T
is equal to 13 that means that this
thing over here is equal to 13 for some
T for some input so we can just solve
the equation a negative 2t plus 5 is
equal to 13 so let's do that negative 2t
plus 5 is equal to 13 well we can
subtract 5 from both sides I'm just
trying to isolate the T on the left hand
side so subtract negative 5 from the
left that's the whole reason why we did
that so those disappear but we have to
do it from the right as well so you have
13 minus 5 is 8 and on the left hand
side you still have your negative 2t so
you have negative 2t is equal to 8 now
to just have a T on the left hand side I
want to divide both sides by negative 2
and I'm left with t is equal to 8
divided by negative 2 is equal to
negative 4
so you input negative 4 you input
negative 4 into this function into this
function and it will output 13 or we
could write that F of negative 4 is
equal to 13 but this is what they're
looking for this is the input value
negative 4 is the input value for which
f of T is equal to 13 f of negative 4 is
equal to 13